okay so a couple things about counting
cards one anyone who uses it it's like
oh I'm a smart person I'll learn to
count cards they're lying to you it's
for more like it's it's all memorization
there's like almost no math it's
counting - it takes an incredibly long
period of time and three you can't make
any money doing it so I don't recommend
when I came back from my first trip to
Reno Nevada
I flew myself to Reno Nevada I came back
and my brother asked how much money did
you make said so so much and so how long
were you there
it looks down looks back and says you
made less than minimum wage anyway I'm a
[ __ ] I'm here to talk to you about
graphs I I really love DataViz I've been
teaching ggplot in various data vis
classes for a little while quick
shoutout to Georgetown and thanks again
indicates for for hosting us here really
excited to see this year I work to help
build this graduate program and this is
the space that I personally am in which
is helping bring modern like data
science computational methods emerging
technologies to Public Policy Research
and government and analysis I think it's
an important space I think a bunch of
you are sort of in that field if you're
interested in this or the space at all
please come talk to me always excited to
meet more people in this in this realm
so that's my quick plug and I'm going to
talk about ggplot so this is from 2015
and I want to get the name of the author
this is Andrew devised in a 2015 talk at
the big DC I'm sorry the big art
conference that use our and either
network graph of all the packages and
package dependencies and if you see the
blue area the dark blue that's like a
lot of ggplot and a little bit of the
tidy verse as well and and one of the
takeaways you could happen this is like
that's a lot of packages there's it the
pure number is very high and the
interconnectedness this is dependencies
but people also use them together for a
figure today right it is really high and
I actually want to make the argument
that that inter dependency with ggplot
is going to remain and it's going to be
like to our benefit
generally and poke a little bit of fun
at our Python II neighbors if you've
never read this article you should it's
hilarious it's a dramatic tour of the
Python data visualization landscape and
it walks through how you can make graphs
in Python using like seven competing
graphing systems and some of them are
quite good boca is quite good plot nine
which is a ggplot2 port is quite good
but there's seven of them and python is
not agreed upon sort of a common
framework for working on visualizations
we are really lucky to have done that
and I think the result of this is a
really high-quality set of packages even
though there's many of them they're
commonly built around ggplot they're
easy to use they give you a lot of extra
functionality and they're not gonna get
absorbed into ggplot that is just not
the model that the core developers and
have Lee has talked about this a couple
of times they're not gonna go take all
this cool extra packages and bring them
to G flat it's gonna be an ecosystem so
I'm gonna bring up seven examples of
packages think they're seven some of the
packages that are low-hanging fruit that
will make your grass better in ggplot
first this was a big updates the SS
these not speacial everyone thinks it's
facial features it's actually simple
features package it's now really well
integrated with ggplot2 ok this is
really cool and at first you might see
something like this and be like wow
finally we can make amazing maps and we
couldn't before this is from like three
years ago without SF so you actually
could make really great maps before the
SF integration this is still a really
big deal for ease-of-use that if you
haven't done this yet I really encourage
you to get into it and really who's a
rock star and geospatial analysis will
be talking tomorrow about using SF and
doing data manipulation with it but the
big difference is you don't have to do
this part anymore this is some of like
this is this core data munging process
of reading in before simple features a
shape file if you look that's the read a
gr that's pointing to a folder it's
looking for a light like
your name which is the name of the shape
file it's using this at operator which
hopefully none of you will ever have to
see again and that's literally because
there's like a data frame stored in an
attribute of the spatial data that you
just read in and you just wrote aims
from that and use a fortify function and
no one knows what that function does so
it makes it into a long data set with a
giant column essentially that has all
like the latitude and longitude points
and then literally it's you're doing all
this work so you can pass it to G on
polygon and this is beautiful but that's
what that's doing it's using G on
polygon to take this very complicated
thing and actually and and there's a
raster file in there too but the the
choropleth part right the the color by
value areas that's coming from GM
polygon and and that's confusing it also
means that you have to use g on pass for
the borders and this was good this was a
solid useful step on our way but it was
confusing it was very hard to teach I
taught this for a while and the new
beauty of SF just completely hides this
from you there's a an ST read function
for reading in spatial data that comes
right from shape files and then you
literally use GM SF and it maps for you
and it's absolutely fantastic it could
not be more straightforward this is the
tutorial I'd point you towards if you
want to follow up drawing beautiful Maps
programmatically if IR s F of G two part
one the basics and I'll just really
quick goals like what's happening that's
great here when you read in data as in
with SC read it becomes an SF object
simple future subject which is also a
data frame the difference is it has like
a column of geometries so rather than
having this crazy series of points and
making this very very long data set that
allows you to track all lots and lots
all of that for each pilot for each
spatial thing could be a polygon could
be lines single line it could be points
that's encompassed in a geometry that
like all of that ends up being in one
cell essentially for our unit and SF is
gonna see this understand that it's
there and say I know how to do with this
there's no SF polygons versus SF points
it's just
jiya mess f4 all of them and you can see
that here I
this is the world data pass it to GMs f
then four counties then four points so
that GM FF is being used three times
twice for polygons once four points data
use the points of the cities and then G
on text because this is all Gigi bought
so you just drop it on top it would be
ridiculous to ask her I mean maybe
people will make this easier this is
it'd be ridiculous hope it gets better
the you know R has gone from G
officinalis is being a real weakness to
being a huge strength and maybe five
years or so nitpick about that but
that's where I see it okay so that's SF
really encourage you to look at that
here's to you might think wow this
beautiful map this map is the thing
that's appealing here but when I saw
this I already knew that maps were great
I got really excited because of the bold
text it's yet this is totally new you
couldn't do this before so the text
right here is bolded and I actually
think it's a really unlike the
Washington looks quite nice this is a
new class will package called Gigi text
and it lets you use G on rich text use
highlighted there at the bottom and it
lets you pass in HTML style markdown on
he or plots and so this is silly example
of why that's what he's doing right he's
passing through a formula with
superscripts blue text italics large
text bold changing sizes right you
couldn't so this is this is nice you
might ask like okay what do I really
want to use this for and here's the
first like tip for visualization I
actually really like the simple use of
this which is highlighting in your title
and description what you wanted people
to draw their attention to so this is a
graph from a student of mine about
maternal mortality and it's the rise of
Poland I'm sorry I cut off some of these
years but this is over about a forty
year period 85 to 2015 and the decline
of the US this is a ranked chart so
we're going down to 95 and so the it's
simple right the coloring in the title
but I'm trying to pretty explicitly draw
your attention for what the title text
is so what I'm trying to show you in the
graph a simple example if you want to
see something more complicated
this is also using um GI Marrakech which
i think is hilarious
these ticking labels and passing it in
actually you see the pictures of the
iris flowers appear that's did you text
okay
highlight Gigi highlight also another
package this might look simple but the
way you would have had to do stuff like
this before is really annoying so if you
wanted to plot a whole bunch of lines
with no color you could just said in
this case group by state this is opioid
deaths over time as a percent of
population so what are you looking at is
West Virginia having a staggering opioid
fatality rate relative to other states
that's why they're all ended up so you
could have got no color just by doing G
online and group by state some colors
you would have had to do two G on lines
one maybe for all the states and another
filtered we're instead of group used
color that would have done it so two
consecutive G on lines or you could have
created a new variable for highlight in
which you know most of the states got no
highlights and some of the states got a
highlight color what Gigi highlight does
is sort of takes that away you can
highlight based on like filters like
where statements so plus G online plus
GG highlight and this is saying max
highlight equals for max fatalities for
capita to take the top five so Max
eyelid is highlight five things and Max
take them by fatality per capita as you
get the top five holiday and if you want
to change this you didn't create a new
variable you didn't use two lines you
can quickly iterate through this like
the G M line you know you don't really
want to be creating a new variable every
time you want to change the colors on a
chart that's not super ideal it works
with faceting too so here's another
example in fact this is actually
changing behavior of facet this is about
this is a graph from a former student
Jonathan tan looking at the changing
cost of solar panels over time and it's
showing three states can I to get
Massachusetts in New Jersey and what's
happening here is its G on step
then GM highlight sodium step working as
you'd expect it
then GM highlight that highlight is only
highlighting there's your your sort of
filter condition so in the first one it
took the top five by a variable you can
also just pass it one or multiple sort
of where style statements right think
like the filter function and type in a
deep wire and then it to specifies an
unhighlight at color and what's
interesting is then he passes it to
facet wrap state and you're seeing it's
only faceting by those three filters
days so again a highlight and a filter
of the fascinating at the same time
would have been more annoying to do that
before
that's GG highlight really easy to use
um the other reason I mention this is
because most of the time if you're using
colors for all of your whatever you're
showing it's too much color too much
information
dramatically overuse colors your Mac
should be six seven five maybe is a good
number
choose your highlight take out what you
don't need focus people's attention
what's important shocking to me how easy
this is now this is what the annotation
custom if you won't feel ease groves
graphical objects sort of kind of groups
are cool you can just basically make a
chart make it a Grob and drop it onto
other charts and like three five so you
make a chart you say like hey be a Grob
please just one function and then you
you just annotate custom plus and then a
group and that's so you get something
like this and I like this because you
have some white space on this bar chart
this is also from Andrea Koch former
students looking at maternal mortality
that it's her don't Aldi by Earth's
which is a problem in the US that's
going up it's going up a lot for
african-american women and looking at
where this is happening in the colors of
the quintiles so you could argue there's
some geospatial like trends here right
the South is not doing as well the West
the United States is doing fairly well
but if the geospatial side isn't like
that strong that the map really becomes
that necessary on its own so maybe you
want the combination of the map
bar chart but all of a sudden that's a
lot of space turns out you can do this
really simply just as I said the top is
the map there's G own SF again you save
that as US map and then you have this
ggplot that you're actually plotting out
an annotation custom and dropping in
that US map and you're just converting
it to a Grob as as you go so if you want
to combine plots that become a lot
easier if you Gigi save this both will
come out there technically in one
viewport which I'm not going to talk
about but it makes it easy to sort of
take this in an export it whatever you
want here's another great example this
is from Dan snow looking at access to
health care so the Blues the darker
blues are better access to health care
just since the doctors into the reds and
yellows which are worse and what I like
about this is he basically said I have
this nice histogram that shows the
distribution of this which is kind of
hard to see from looking at the map
remember you can't look at the map
because these are counties and say well
I see a lot of blue that means there are
more counties that are blue they're
counties they're changing sizes right
you just can't sort of infer that so
what he wanted to include the histogram
and then essentially replaced the scale
with the histogram and admittedly you
don't see numbers on there because the
metric is kind of a complicated math you
metric but high is high axis very low as
low access and again same thing made a
histogram made a map shaved a Zagreb
dropped it with annotation custom one
note about when you may not want to do
that something like this so this might
be right but I don't recommend it what
the student said here is they made a box
plot and histogram they extended the
y-axis on the histogram to a negative
space and then use annotation custom to
drop it into the same space this might
be right but I just want to remind
everyone and so that's what they did
remind everyone that when you take a
Grob and this is just for the sake of
example taking groves and dropping them
big
come with a lot of space around them
they come with the axis they come with
to come with the margins it's probably
not a good idea to put different graphs
on the same scale within a single plot
so if they're not on the same scale
probably fine if they are you probably
want something like this which is from G
table right so you want something to
separate charts on the same scale it
doesn't really replace that does allow
you to put two things in the same place
though and this is G table easy universe
for that but here's one more example of
annotation custom doing something cool
you might think that's pretty hard this
is actually pretty straightforward code
you create a bounding box around New
York this is all the doctors in the US
you put a bounding box around New York
literally use define a set a latitude
and longitudes you put a bounding box in
the Atlantic Ocean you create two maps
one that zoomed in and one for the whole
country and drop the smaller one in so
these are the two bounding boxes again
there's some st stuff in here but if
you're interested in that angeles talk
tomorrow well I think cover this and
hopefully not volunteering too much for
her but you're literally trading like a
box in a map pod use a box in the
Atlantic Ocean
you're subsetting the points that are in
the box in New York making two Maps one
with all the points one with there's the
map the points in the New York and here
you're dropping that small plot into the
and as a Grob so and if you're running
those who just like dotted lines with GM
and at eight segments or something like
that
between the kinetochores this is the
kind of thing you might be able to do it
just a little bit of annotate a custom
entertainin groves and again it's pretty
low hanging fruit I like facets
I like facet geo and this also is really
easy this is from Jonathan tan former so
almost all this is this talk should have
been called like cribbing ideas for my
students I think I proposed that and
they rejected it like I think that
happens
this is facet geo it's showing you solar
panel optics or how many solar panels
there are in the US and
then the colored bars are the existence
of solar panel incentive programs in the
states and the students actually saying
that they didn't seem to be that related
that was their takeaway point the
argument with something like facet geo
is not necessarily that the that like
the geospatial side is that important
it's that this is actually faster to
find what you an individual from a state
might care about than a grid that is an
alphabetic order so if you know you're
looking for California or Maine it's
actually pretty easy to glance in the
direction that's getting you give very
close to that actually much faster than
like a grid alphabetically would and
fast at you is really easy to use
Gyan step GM rekt pacify state that's
the dubai state there are some built in
but you're like how many could possibly
be built in this one is for brazilian
states which i think is quite nice and
in fact there are 62 of these built in
by defaults which i thought was quite a
few and you can build your own with the
geogrid designer so if you like fasted
you and you want to build one for a set
of provinces but these are made up
countries from various TV shows san
borja is the one that only rich people
can afford I think in 30 rock I love
that true anyway so passage you are
really easy and again the framework for
you to build your own stuff and sort of
do that faceting across the geographic
area is quite nice any evaluation so
when I almost certainly should have I
shouldn't have included this so it's
it's really interesting but I'm just
unqualified to talk about it so I don't
really understand tidy evaluation but
I'm gonna explain one use of it anyway
I read chapter 19 and 20 of advance are
at some point and he just didn't stick
but I do understand this I understand
that gender and mass as variables in in
the Star Wars data don't exist in the
global namespace and thus they like when
I try to do this they'd like nothing
happens right there you get there's
errors I get that right I feel like
everyone sort of vaguely understands
that the tiny versus doing something
that makes the tidy functions recognize
variable names cool okay and I get it
because of that it's hard to pass liked
ID versus functions that you're used to
using into functions because it's
interpreting things differently right so
here when you try to create data bar and
by in a function name and pass those two
Teddybears functions you get an error on
this side so this bottom part works and
we like that but it causes this slightly
tricky problem tidy evaluation lets you
kind of have the best of both worlds and
in this case what it lets you do is have
things that you want interpret as a
string interpreted as a string and have
things you want interpreted as a
variable name interpreters available
that it turns out is very useful in
ggplot this is the other thing fully
integrated in the teapot 3.0 along with
SF and this is an example from Aaron
Williams and he's right to include it
cuz he argued for this and he's right
too because it's really interesting what
it lets you do which is I don't think
anyone's gonna be able to read this and
understand it without an understanding
of Ted evaluation but this is what it
acts this is actually what it lets you
do which is in one function I can make
tab set function output into our
markdown like that's what you get out of
that if I can treat this variable as a
string when I want it to be a string and
pass it into GT plot as a function what
I want to and that's new it's like it's
relatively important if you want to do
plot to work as part of a function or
like in function programming and the
last part it's just this is 7:07 this is
a small number of the extensions this is
some of the ones I really like but
there's a ton and again I think they're
gonna stay sort of external to ggplot
core this is GG ridges and it's
beautiful and simple this is GG mosaic
of stop-and-frisk this is horizon GG
horizon from GG alts this is a
ridiculous one if you want half a violin
plots but like the pure number of them
is like amazing and I encourage you to
go and check out this whole like really
amazing ecosystem of sort of our rounds
ggplot the GG plot extensions is is
probably the best site for that and
stop there because I'm a little over
reishi aiders cool - yeah sure all right
all right radiator
so ratio or does two things it makes
ridiculous maps that like just blows my
mind and then and this is hasn't done
too much yet but it also turns to G
plots 3d and that's all one function it
just took the GG plot and made it 3d and
it's only doing that by taking the color
variable and projecting it into 3d but I
think this if you want another thing I'm
excited for in the GG let's place it
sits right shader okay now I'll really
stop thanks so much everybody feel free
to shout
[Applause]